>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Good afternoon, and welcome.
My name is Mary Lou Reker
and on behalf of the Library
of Congress's John W. Kluge
Center, I want to welcome you
to a talk today by Dr. Rachel
Shelden entitled, "Abraham Lincoln
and the US Supreme Court and
the Politics of Slavery".
Now, before I get started
here, I want to remind you
that we are recording this
for the library's website,
so any questions you may ask at
the end constitute your permission
to keep that question
in the recording.
So, just be aware of that.
Many of you know that the
Kluge Center is located right
through those doors, up
here on Capitol Hill.
And it strives to bring together
scholars and researchers to make use
of the collections of the Library
of Congress and to communicate
with policymakers across the
city and around the country.
And also to foster a
collegial atmosphere
in which scholarship can
generate more scholarship
and deeper scholarship.
Dr. Rachel Shelden has
been an integral member
of the community here at the
Kluge Center this past year.
Her research at the library focuses
on the US Supreme Court
during the 19th century.
Her talk will examine the Supreme
Court before the Civil War,
and in particular, a conspiracy
charge to perpetuate slavery,
which was levied by the
then senatorial candidate,
Abraham Lincoln, against
a variety of members
of the federal government.
Shelden will reexamine Lincoln's
conspiracy charge in the context
of how the federal political system,
and particularly the
US Supreme Court,
operated in the mid-19th century.
Rachel Shelden is an assistant
professor in American History
at the University of Oklahoma.
She is the author of "Washington
Brotherhood, Politics, Social Life
and the Coming of the Civil War".
She is also coeditor of the book,
"A Political Nation, New Directions
in Mid-Nineteenth Century
American Political Theory".
She received her PhD from
the University of Virginia,
and as a Kluge Fellow,
researched her future monograph,
the third here.
"On the Political History
of the US Supreme Court
from the Mid-1830s
through the 1890s".
Please help me welcome
her, Dr. Rachel Shelden.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much.
And thank you, Mary Lou.
Before I talk about Lincoln, which I
know you're all here to hear about,
I want to thank all of the wonderful
folks at the Library of Congress
for supporting my project.
It has been an absolute
privilege to be a Kluge Fellow.
And the Kluge Center really
is a special place to work.
I want to thank all of the
staff, and particularly Mary Lou.
Jason Steinhauer, Joanne Kitchens,
Dan Turello, Robert Gallucci
and Travis Hensley, among others.
As always, I had a wonderful
experience researching
in the Manuscript Division, and
I want to thank Michelle Crowell,
who's here, who helped me
out in a number of ways,
in addition to the incredibly
knowledgeable reference staff
for all of their help, and
especially their good cheer.
While in residence, I had the
wonderful opportunity to work
with Kluge Center intern, Jack
Femol [presumed spelling].
He helped with the database
project on the Supreme Court cases
and lawyers, which has
proved tremendously useful
in my research so far.
And finally, I want to thank all
of the fellows for their many,
many pointed insights,
their heartfelt support
and engaging conversation.
So, with that said, I want
to tell you a little bit
about the larger project that I have
been doing here at the Kluge Center.
I've been working on a political
history of the Supreme Court
in the Civil War era, from
roughly the 1830s to the 1890s.
My project is primarily
concerned with the ways
in which the Supreme
Court was and acted
as a political body
during this period.
And one of the key points
that I intend to make is
that we should think about the
Supreme Court, not as a separate
and isolated institution,
but rather as an integral
and interconnected part
of the federal political
apparatus in the 19th century.
As the evidence here at
the library demonstrated
in the incredible sources
in the Jefferson Building
and in the Manuscript
Division in numerous letters
from Supreme Court Justices and the
lawyers who tried cases in front
of them, the experience
and the context of serving
as a Supreme Court Justice
was inherently political.
In essence, political history
is about the Supreme Court, too.
Reframing our understanding
of the court
in this context can tell us much
about the way 19th century
Supreme Court justices thought
about their roles in promoting
democracy, union and liberty.
But the justices' political behavior
also influenced their engagement
with some of the most
important issues of this period,
particularly issues
involving slavery and race.
There are a number of ways to get at
this relationship between politics,
the Supreme Court and slavery
and race in the mid-19th century,
but given that we have just passed
Lincoln's birthday late last week,
I thought there was no better entry
point into the political history
of the Supreme Court
in the Civil War era.
So, I want to start with a
famous political accusation
that Lincoln made about an equally
famous Supreme Court ruling.
In June, 1858, Abraham Lincoln
delivered an address at Springfield,
Illinois, that has come to be known
as his "House Divided" speech.
This was a speech many of you
are undoubtedly familiar with.
Lincoln began, "A house divided
against itself cannot stand.
I believe this government cannot
endure permanently half slave
and half free."
As Lincoln explained, the
United States would have
to go one direction or the other.
Become an entirely
non-slaveholding nation,
or an entirely slaveholding nation.
The opening section of the
speech is the most famous piece,
probably the piece you have heard.
But the rest of the address
is equally noteworthy.
Here Lincoln developed
and explained his theory
that there was a conspiracy
among four men
to spread slavery throughout
the United States.
To make this an entirely
slaveholding nation
by making slavery legal not
only in the southern states,
but in the north, as well.
The men in this conspiracy were
Lincoln's chief rival in Illinois,
Stephen Douglas, and three
other federal leaders,
former president Franklin
Pierce, President James Buchanan
and Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court, Roger Taney.
According to Lincoln, the
conspiracy began in 1854
when Stephen Douglas introduced the
Kansas-Nebraska Act into the Senate.
Douglas's bill upended a
30-plus year ban on slavery
in the US Territory above the 36'
30" Latitude, or what we think
of as the line that
separates south from north.
Instead, the Kansas-Nebraska
act implemented the principle
of popular sovereignty, or the
ability of people in the territory
to vote in favor or against
slavery in their borders.
According to Lincoln, three years
later, the Supreme Court finalized
and compounded the move toward
nationalizing slavery in the case
of Dred Scott v. Sanford.
On March 6th 1857, Chief
Justice, Roger Taney,
read the majority opinion
in Dred Scott,
which denied African
Americans the right
to be citizens of the United States.
And in the most consequential
part of this particular ruling
for Lincoln's charge,
prohibited congress
from restricting slavery
in the US Territories.
Now, in between these two monumental
moves, outgoing president,
Franklin Pierce, had
encouraged acceptance
of the Kansas-Nebraska legislation
and any potential consequences
that came from it.
And a mere two days before the court
issued its decision in Dred Scott,
the incoming president,
James Buchanan,
pressed his inaugural audience
to accept whatever the
court might decide.
Lincoln finally connected
the circle back to Douglas,
who was similarly insistent
that the court receive its due.
In the weeks before Buchanan's
inauguration, Douglas had been asked
by an Illinois colleague
on the floor of the senate
if it was constitutional for
the people of a territory
to ban slavery from their borders.
Douglas replied that this was a
question for the Supreme Court.
So, with so many overlapping
connections, Lincoln exclaimed
in his "House Divided" speech, "We
find it impossible to not believe
that Steven and Franklin and Roger
and James all understood one another
from the beginning, and all worked
upon a common plan or draft drawn
up before the first
lick was struck."
Now, on its face, this
charge might seem outlandish.
There is no evidence to suggest
that these four men met in a room
and hashed out a plan for Douglas
to introduce the Kansas-Nebraska Act
in 1854 and Taney to
rule in Dred Scott.
And in the formalized debates
between Lincoln and Douglas
that followed, the debates
you're familiar with, I'm sure,
the Lincoln-Douglas Debates of 1858,
Douglas repeatedly
denied having spoken
to Chief Justice Taney
about the matter.
He also pointed out, Douglas, that
Buchanan was serving as Minister
to London when he introduced
the Kansas-Nebraska Act,
making any conference among the
four men in 1854 before the first
of Lincoln's conspiratorial
moves, wholly impossible.
So, why did Lincoln
make this charge?
Or perhaps more pointedly,
did Lincoln really believe
that these men had
colluded in a plot
to spread slavery throughout
the United States?
Some Lincoln scholars have argued
that Lincoln genuinely
believed this.
If for no other reason,
than his abject distrust
of his rival, Stephen Douglas.
Other scholars have been
less sure, suggesting instead
that Lincoln made sort of a
fanciful argument for the sake
of making Douglas look bad.
After all, Lincoln was in a
heated campaign against Douglas
for election to the US
Senate from Illinois,
and Lincoln was doing all he
could to defeat his rival.
In fact, earlier in the
year, some republicans
from the east had suggested
that maybe they were going
to support Douglas for
his senatorial bid,
and this really freaked Lincoln
out and made him think, "Oh,
I really need to show
that the democrats are not
in a good way on this issue."
The political benefit, therefore,
of this conspiracy
charge, was substantial.
And some evidence sustains
this interpretation
that Lincoln was simply
playing a political game.
In the joint debates with
Douglas that followed his
"House Divided" speech,
Lincoln repeated the charge.
But he was very careful
to acknowledge
that he could not prove
the conspiracy.
That he had only inferred that
such collusion had taken place.
Regardless of whether Lincoln
believed the charge or not,
the suggestion of conspiracy
among federal politicians made
for some great political theater.
Much like today, charges
of conspiracy
in the Civil War era sent a powerful
message that energized voters.
And this particular conspiracy
charge had rhetorical legs,
because of the plausibility
of the argument.
Certainly, southern slaveholders
were intent on preserving
and promoting slavery in their
states and in new federal territory.
And anti-slavery men in the north
had been thoroughly disgusted
by Douglas's role in
the Kansas-Nebraska Act.
Many saw the introduction of popular
sovereignty into the territories
as a victory for slaveholders.
Certainly, the recent
tendency to expand the power
of slavery made a slaveholder
conspiracy sound more likely.
And in fact, several republicans
in Washington had already been
exploiting this northern fear
of a slaveholder conspiracy
by the time Lincoln delivered
his "House Divided" speech.
But Lincoln's description
of the conspiracy was
perhaps even more effective.
Because it had the sound bite
specifics that others had lacked.
He fleshed out the details by
naming the four co-conspirators
who were directly responsible
for this.
Stephen and Franklin
and Roger and James.
The conspiracy featured
democrats from all three branches
of the federal government,
working in concert over some time,
culminating in a case
before the Supreme Court.
And in many ways, this
part of the conspiracy,
Taney's role in the Dred Scott case,
is the part that looks most
ethically questionable to all of us.
We're used to the idea that
the president and members
of congress might work together
to promote an agenda or a piece
of legislation, though, especially
these days, that might rely
on a president and congress
being of the same party.
What was really galling about
Lincoln's charge, to us at least,
is that at least one member of
the Supreme Court was in on it.
But Lincoln was no less certain that
Roger had played a critical role.
And I think this is
really important.
We could simply assume Lincoln
was exaggerating the level
of the Supreme Court's rule,
as some historians have.
But I think that misses
what was really going on.
For Lincoln, the conspiracy
was plausible,
not just because of
recent pro-slavery moves,
but because of who was
involved in those moves.
And the "who" included Roger Taney.
The key here is that
Lincoln recognized
that the Supreme Court was not
simply a legal body deciding cases
in the vacuum of the court chamber.
Rather, he knew first hand that
the court was intimately connected
to the other branches of government,
both in personnel and in operation.
There were no stark lines
separating senators from justices
or even judge from lawyer.
In fact, this is an
aspect of Lincoln's life
that does not get enough attention.
Lincoln is known for his brilliant
political mind both in the debates
with Douglas and then, of course,
in his years as president during
our nation's most difficult moment,
the Civil War.
But Lincoln spent most
of his career,
before becoming president,
as a lawyer.
Perhaps we have ignored this,
in part, because our perception
of lawyers is not always
very positive today.
And this was actually true
in the 19th century, as well.
Lincoln acknowledged as
much in preparing some notes
for a law lecture in 1850.
He noted, "There is a
vague popular belief
that lawyers are necessarily
dishonest.
The impression is common,
almost universal."
[Laughter] So, perhaps, given
this perception in our rush
to celebrate Lincoln's important
role in our national story,
we sometimes minimize
his legal contributions.
But Lincoln had intimate
knowledge, not only of the law,
but also the structures
of the Judicial System.
Lincoln and his several law partners
over the years had
a bustling business,
trying cases in the
Illinois Court System.
Historians estimate that
Lincoln's law practice was involved
in nearly 5,000 cases
on the state level.
And he was also involved in nearly
350 cases on the federal level,
including several that
reached the Supreme Court.
Although Lincoln only made
oral arguments in front
of the Supreme Court once during
his career, in all likelihood,
this was not his only experience
with the court's proceedings.
Until the 20th century,
as you may know,
the court's chamber was located
in the chamber of the Capitol.
And Lincoln had spent enough time
in the Capitol building during his
single term as a US Congressman,
to know that the line
between legislative
and judicial branches
was often blurry.
In essence, Lincoln was intimately
experienced with the ways
in which the federal system
operated at each level.
Ultimately, from this experience
in Washington, and in trying cases
in the Illinois state and
federal courts, Lincoln understood
that the 19th century
judiciary often operated
in fluid and informal ways.
Whether he actually believed
his own accusations or not,
Lincoln's understanding
of the Supreme Court
as a political body gave even
more plausibility to the idea
that a conspiracy had occurred.
And Lincoln clearly
framed his charge
with this understanding in mind.
So, in the remainder
of my time here,
I want to show you just how
important this judicial context was
by highlighting some
of the political
and legal relationships
of the mid-19th century.
Relationships that Lincoln
would have been familiar
with when making his
conspiracy charge.
In particular, I want to focus
on the two types of relationships
that I just mentioned, that would
have given Lincoln the special
knowledge to see collusion.
First, the Washington political
community and second the community
of lawyers and judges that
practiced both in Washington
and throughout the
federal court system.
By the end, perhaps you will be as
convinced as Lincoln purported to be
that Stephen and Franklin and
Roger and James were colluding
in the Dred Scott decision.
So, I'll start with the
Washington political community.
A community that very much
included the Supreme Court.
Today, we often assume a very
strict level of separation
between the Supreme Court and the
Legislative and Executive Branches.
But, as Lincoln would have noted,
in the 19th century, the boundaries
between these bodies
were much blurrier.
To begin with, there was no stark
line separating Supreme Court
Justices from members of Congress.
The fact that the court chamber
was located in the Capitol itself,
helped to ensure that congressional
and judicial business
sometimes overlapped.
And overlapped is perhaps
the best word.
A number of congressmen served as
lawyers before the Supreme Court
in the era of Dred Scott.
In fact, Congressmen
were paid so little
for their legislative services
that it was a happy coincidence
if a sitting senator or
representative could take care
of some profitable
legal business in front
of the court while in Washington.
Lincoln understood this well,
having argued his only case in front
of the Supreme Court at the
close of his term in the House
of Representatives in 1849.
Occasionally, congressmen argued
Supreme Court cases in the midst
of pressing congressional
business, requiring them to work
with the justices to schedule
arguments for days when congress was
in recess, or to simply miss the
legislative meetings entirely.
Perhaps the most famous
example of this kind of juggling
at an important moment was when New
York Senator William Henry Seward
was arguing a case in front of
the court in December, 1860.
If you know anything about what
was happening in December 1860,
this is right in the midst of South
Carolina threatening to secede
from the union and, as a senator,
William Henry Seward was
very involved in trying
to prevent this from happening.
So, he's juggling these things.
In the case of Dred Scott,
Lincoln was undoubtedly aware
that Henry Geyer, a sitting
congressman from Missouri,
was one of the lawyers from the
named parties, John Sanford.
Congressmen were not the
only ones to blur the lines
between government branches.
Just as legislative members
engaged in judicial business,
so too did judiciary members
engage in legislative business.
There are numerous examples in
this period of a justice working
on congressional legislation
behind the scenes.
Often, but not always, this
meant helping congressmen
to craft laws regarding the federal
court system or other legal matters.
But sometimes, this was completely
separate from legal issues.
Supreme Court Justices and
Congressmen also interacted
in more social ways
than they do today.
In the 1840s and 1850s, Supreme
Court Justices often lived
in boarding houses and
hotels throughout the area
between the White House
and the Capitol Building.
And while some on the Dred Scott
Court like Taney confined themselves
to small houses with just
a few other justices,
others were more inclined
to mix with other members
of the Washington community,
including members of congress.
For example, associate justice,
John McLean, often rented rooms
at Mrs. Carter's Boarding
House, where he lived
with upwards of ten congressmen.
And in the late 1840s when
Lincoln served in the House
of Representatives, one of McLean's
mess mates was Lincoln's good
friend, Alexander Stephens.
If the Supreme Court Justices
did not live with members
of the Washington community,
they were still sure to interact
with them on a wide
variety of occasions.
This happened most frequently
at the dinner table of friends
or prominent city residents.
On more formal occasions, the
justices went to state dinners
at the White House or
to various celebrations,
like the annual Birthnight Ball,
which honored George
Washington's birthday.
But still, other times,
their dinners took place
in more casual circumstances.
Sometimes, such dinners featured
both justices and the lawyers
who were making oral
arguments in court that week.
If the social and professional
interaction between congressmen
and justices does not convince you
that the line between the judicial
and legislative branches
were blurry,
perhaps I can state the
case more definitively.
There is significant
evidence that members
of the Supreme Court discussed
open cases with the senators
and representatives who
tried cases in front of them.
Sometimes, these discussions
involved a justice simply filling
in a friend that he had
lost a case a couple
of days before the
decision was made,
but others featured conversations
about a case still
under consideration.
Lincoln did not have
personal experience
with this kind of conversation.
At least, there's no evidence
to suggest that in the records.
But he certainly would have
been aware of this kind of thing
from his time serving in Washington,
or heard about it from friends
in the House who were
regular court attendees.
So, this is one kind
of relationship.
This very fluid relationship
between the legislative
and judicial branches.
The relationships between
judges on the Supreme Court
and sitting presidents in the 19th
century were also far more intimate
than we might expect.
One reason for this is that
justices did not have the same kinds
of credentials that they do today.
Supreme Court nominees
had to be lawyers,
but there were very few
law schools in the 1850s.
Most American Lawyers had received
their formal training by serving
in an apprentice role from
a more experienced lawyer,
though you did not have to do this.
And Lincoln himself had
almost no legal training.
He'd not even apprenticed.
He'd learned the law primarily
from reading Blackstone's
Commentaries and by trying cases.
Moreover, justices did not
typically enter the Supreme Court
from a previous position
on the Bench.
There were no feeder courts
from which presidents
could find a farm team
of suitable judges as
the often do today.
Of the nine justices who
served on the Dred Scott Court,
only five had experience as
judges before they joined the
Supreme Court.
And of those five, only
two were serving as judges
when they were nominated
to the court.
So, as a result of this
relatively informal legal
and judicial training, political
experience was often the best
indicator for who would
join the Supreme Court.
Nineteenth century presidents
typically made Supreme Court
nominations based squarely
on partisan reasoning,
rewarding political friends
with a job in the judiciary.
Among the seven Dred Scott justices
who were not serving as justices
when they were nominated to the
Supreme Court, two were serving
in the Executive Branch,
one was a US Congressman,
and a fourth held a
prominent state position
as Lieutenant Governor or Virginia.
These men were rewarded for
their political commitments,
not their judicial service.
Roger Taney, himself, had received
his nomination for Chief Justice
from President Andrew Jackson in
1836 as a result of Taney's support
for Jackson's banking policies.
Taney was certainly
a qualified lawyer,
but he was also a strong democrat,
and a confident of Andrew Jackson's.
In 1846, James K. Polk had
actually toyed with the idea
of making James Buchanan a Supreme
Court nominee while Buchanan was
serving as Secretary of State.
Buchanan was a strong democrat,
but he'd also been giving Polk
some headaches in the cabinet,
and so he thought, Polk
thought, putting Buchanan
on the court would
make perfect sense.
It would give him an ally and it
would get him out of the cabinet.
Ultimately, Buchanan decided
against accepting the nomination,
but the possibility was there.
And Buchanan's political
experience was a positive
in Polk's considerations.
The Supreme Court might actually
have looked slightly different
and decided Dred Scott
slightly differently,
had Millard Fillmore been
successful in nominating one
of his partisan friends to
the court in early 1853.
Fillmore was a Whig and
he hoped to get his friend
and former senate colleague, George
Edmund Badger of North Carolina,
on the court to replace
Associate Justice, John McKinley,
who had died the July before.
But the democratic congress rejected
Badger and the next president,
Franklin Pierce, successfully
nominated John Archibald Campbell
of Alabama.
Although Badger was a
southerner, following the decision,
Badger came out against the court's
restriction of congress's right
to legislate for the territories
in the case of slavery.
So, had he been on the court, things
might have looked very different.
So, although partisanship clearly
mattered when making nominations,
what's most important
here is that confirmation
as a Supreme Court Justice
did not actually bring an end
to the close relationships
between president and judge.
Taney, for example, was close enough
with Jackson to actually provide him
with constitutional advice
during his presidency.
And he even helped the retiring
president write his farewell address
in 1837.
Nor was Taney alone.
Fellow associate justices on the
Dred Scott Court, Peter Daniel
and John Catron, similarly offered
political advice to their friends,
President Martin Van Buren and
President James Polk, respectively.
Justices also routinely advised
presidents and their cabinets
on judicial matters from who
should fill court vacancies,
to navigating sticky legal
problems such as extradition.
Lincoln may not have had first-hand
knowledge of these conversations,
but he would have known plenty
of federal politicians who did.
The line between the
federal, judicial
and executive departments
was actually so blurry
that several judges actively sought
their own presidential nomination
while sitting on the Supreme Court.
The most consistent candidate
for president among the Dred Scott
court justices was John McLean
of Ohio, a frontrunner
for nomination
in every presidential contest
between 1832 and 1860, and,
I should add, representing
nearly every political party
of the antebellum era, including
anti-masons, Whigs, Free Soilers,
Americans, Republicans and
Constitutional Unionists [laughter].
Only nine months before
the decision in Dred Scott,
McLean had been a favorite
to win the nomination
at the Republican National
Convention in Philadelphia.
Lincoln had been among the
nominees for vice president
at the 1856 convention, and he
was therefore intimately familiar
with this kind of cross
branch behavior.
So, I hope I've convinced you
the Supreme Court that operated
in Lincoln's time was not isolated.
The lines between the highest US
Court and the other two branches
of government were blurry
and sometimes fluid.
And Lincoln made his conspiracy
charge with this context in mind.
Now, Lincoln also had
additional proof
of cross branch interaction
in the Dred Scott case.
Remember that on March 4, 1857,
a mere two days before Taney
issued the decision in Dred Scott,
James Buchanan had been sworn
in as the 15th president
of the United States.
And he told the inaugural
crowd that they ought
to accept whatever the
Supreme Court decided.
On his way up to the podium to
deliver this inaugural address,
the president elect stopped briefly
to have a little conversation
with Chief Justice Taney.
Republican politicians
and newspapers throughout
the north commented
on this very public
discussion between the two men,
suggesting that they exchanged
words about Dred Scott.
Lincoln did not know what
was said, and neither do we.
But it certainly looked
like collusion.
And with Lincoln's
knowledge of the intimacies
between the various
branches of government,
the events on inauguration day may
have looked like a smoking gun.
What Lincoln didn't know is
that this short conversation
between Chief Justice Taney
and the president elect was
just the tip of the iceberg.
In the weeks before
Buchanan's inauguration,
he had exchanged several letters
with one of the associate justices,
John Catron of Tennessee.
Catron had been keeping
Buchanan apprised
of the court's deliberations
over Dred Scott.
But his correspondence went
beyond just sharing information.
Not all of the justices had yet
decided how they were going to rule
on the Missouri Compromise issue.
That's the issue regarding whether
Congress had the right to legislate
for the territories
regarding slavery.
Among the undecideds
was Associate Justice,
Robert Grier of Pennsylvania,
a friend of Buchanan's.
Catron wrote to Buchanan and
asked him to "drop Grier a line"
to suggest he fall in with
Taney's majority position.
Here, then, is one
link in the conspiracy
that Lincoln had anticipated,
even without direct knowledge
of the Buchanan-Catron
correspondence.
You might say that Taney and
Buchanan were in on it together.
We don't have any solid
evidence that Pierce
or Douglas would have discussed
the details of Dred Scott
with members of the Supreme Court.
But their knowledge of the case
may have stemmed from another part
of the legal community, the
relationship between lawyers
and judges throughout
the federal system.
Now, the relationship between these
federal judges and the lawyers
who tried cases in front of them
was understandably intimate.
In the 19th century, the Supreme
Court Bar was relatively small
and justices repeatedly saw the
same lawyers in case after case.
While there were certainly cases
involving first timers before the
bar, there were some
standard-bearers.
Daniel Webster, Richard Cox, George
Bibb, John Sergeant, John Crittenden
and Henry Stanbery show up
repeatedly in the records
as having argued cases from a vast
number of original jurisdictions.
Several lawyers, many of
whom were former congressmen,
set up law offices in
Washington for the simple purpose
of attracting Supreme Court cases.
And as one Washington
resident remarked,
a congressman turned
lawyer was expected
to have some influence
with the justices.
We've seen this already with some
of the congressmen who tried cases
in front of the justices.
But the men who served
as attorneys general
in the antebellum years also tended
to develop intimate relationships
with the Supreme Court
members returning
to the Supreme Court repeatedly in
the years after they left office.
In the 1850s, one of the favorites
on the Supreme Court
was Reverdy Johnson,
one of the lawyers for John Sanford.
Johnson was an intimate
friend of Chief Justice Taney,
and had been trying cases in front
of the Supreme Court for as long
as most of the members had
been sitting on the bench.
In fact, Johnson was well known
in Washington for his influence
with the justices, as they
spent time together at public
and private parties, state
dinners and more intimate affairs.
While there is no direct evidence
that Johnson had ex parte
communication with the justices
about the Dred Scott Case,
his reputation suggested he often
knew the court's proclivities
in other matters.
Lincoln would have understood well
that judges sometimes had close
relationships with the lawyers
who tried cases before them.
He had undoubtedly
witnessed this while serving
as a congressman in Washington.
But perhaps more importantly,
he had personal experience
with a close lawyer-judge
relationship
on a state and local level.
One of Lincoln's best friends
in Illinois was David Davis,
a state lawyer who rode the circuit
with Lincoln throughout the 1840s.
But in 1848, Illinois residents
elected Davis the judge
of the 8th Judicial
Circuit of Illinois.
And Lincoln soon began trying
cases in front of his friend.
While there's no smoking gun that
Lincoln had ex parte communications
with Davis, several
anecdotes and letters
from the time suggest the two men
may have discussed pending legal
issues outside the courtroom.
And in fact, the line between judge
and lawyer blended even further
when Davis needed to attend
to personal business
outside the circuit.
And he put Lincoln on
the bench temporarily
to attend to judicial duties.
This was no small matter.
Lincoln acted as circuit court
judge for Davis in over 300 cases.
And Lincoln, as you may know,
successfully nominated David Davis
to the Supreme Court in 1862.
So, they remained friends
a long time.
While the state court saw a
greater rotation of lawyers,
the Supreme Court bar was small
enough that occasionally a relative
of one of the justices would
find himself trying a case
in front of the bench.
For example.
Taney's brother-in-law,
Francis Scott Key,
occasionally made oral arguments
in the court in the Dred Scott era.
Taney recused himself in at least
one of these cases, but the presence
of a relative did not
necessarily mean a recusal.
One of the true oddities of
the Dred Scott Case itself,
at least to our modern eyes,
is that one of Dred Scott's
lawyers was George Ticknor Curtis,
the brother of one of the associate
justices, Benjamin Robbins Curtis.
The judge did not recuse himself.
And Benjamin Curtis actually
received several compliments
from his fellow justices for his
brother's performance in court.
Now, I see now contemporary
complaints
that Benjamin Curtis heard the case,
in spite of his brother's presence.
Lincoln did not point it out,
perhaps because Curtis was one
of the two dissenters in Dred Scott,
and therefore had earned
republican praise.
But it certainly gives fodder to the
argument that Supreme Court Justices
and the lawyers who try
cases in front of them,
had more than a simple
professional relationship.
And finally, the second aspect
of the federal court system
that I would like to point out
as relevant to Lincoln's charges,
and this is the federal court system
and its structure in this era,
particularly the federal
circuit courts.
The intermediary federal
judicial body
between the district
and Supreme Court.
As some of you may know,
in the antebellum era,
there were no judges whose sole duty
was to sit on the circuit court.
Rather, the circuit
court was composed
of two justices who
had other positions.
A sitting district
judge for the area,
and a US Supreme Court member
who was riding circuit.
As a result of this arrangement,
the circuit court only met a couple
of specified times per year, and in
order to have both justices present,
they needed to account for
the intense travel schedules
of the Supreme Court
men who were responsible
for at least three different
circuit courts in addition
to handling business in Washington.
The staffing of the circuit courts,
with one man from the district
and one man from the Supreme
Court, lent itself to all kinds
of manipulation and
maneuvering among the justices.
For example, a member
of the Supreme Court
who was riding circuit
might purposely split
with his fellow judge to make
sure the case could be appealed
to the highest body.
Or, as in the case with Dred Scott,
the absence of the Supreme Court
Justice form the circuit during
that body's deliberations
could influence when
and how quickly the
case could be appealed.
Lincoln, as I mentioned previously,
would have understood this
system well, having tried cases
in the 7th Federal Circuit
repeatedly for Justice McLean.
So, how does this context factor
into what actually
happened in Dred Scott?
Unlike our Buchanan-Catron smoking
gun, there's no direct evidence
that Douglas or Pierce knew
about the court's decision
in Dred Scott ahead of time, but
if we look a little bit closer
at Lincoln's charges, we might
be able to see some connections.
In his "House Divided" speech,
Lincoln specifically made a link
between the year that the
Kansas-Nebraska Act passed
through congress and when the Dred
Scott Case first entered the federal
court system.
Although a version
of the case had gone
through the Missouri State
Court since the late 1840s,
the suit that we know as Dred Scott
v. Sanford reached the 8th Federal
Circuit in Missouri in early 1854.
Lincoln emphasized that the
1854 date was not a coincidence,
and perhaps he was right.
The justice who was
supposed to serve
on the 8th circuit was
John Catron, remember,
the man who had written
Buchanan for a little help
with his colleague, Justice Grier.
But Catron was not present
for the circuit court session
that began the first
Monday in April.
And although the district
judge, Robert Wells,
could have postponed
the case until October,
he decided to go ahead in April.
Both Catron and Wells had been
serving on the 8th Circuit Court
since their appointments
in the late 1830s,
and they would have known
each other intimately.
It's possible that the two discussed
how to proceed with the case,
though there's no direct
evidence to support that.
Ultimately, I don't actually know
why Wells didn't wait for Catron,
and given that Wells was more
sympathetic to Dred Scott's plea,
I'm not sure he was really involved
in any collusion with Catron
to get the case moving
so that it would coincide
with the Kansas-Nebraska Act.
But you can see how
this looked to Lincoln,
a man who understood the federal
legal system and its penchant
for manipulation quite well.
And so, here we can tie
Douglas to the court,
if not Taney specifically,
perhaps just Catron.
And what about the final piece
of the puzzle, Pierce and Taney?
Again, no direct evidence
that Pierce knew how
the court would decide.
But if we extend out net a little
bit further into Pierce's cabinet,
we might have some answers.
You might remember that the Supreme
Court originally heard the Dred
Scott Case in 1856 while
Pierce was still in office.
One prominent historian has
suggested that Taney had been
in direct conversation with Pierce's
attorney general, Caleb Cushing.
And they had talked about the case,
and how it ought to be decided.
Circumstantial evidence from after
the decision may back this up.
In November, 1857, after the case
was published in Howard's reports,
Taney wrote a letter
to Cushing thanking him
for his support for their decision.
Cushing, who was from Massachusetts,
was among a handful of northerners
who had expressed their approval
of the Dred Scott decision.
But he may have known ahead of time.
And certainly it would
not be farfetched
to assume he discussed
the matter with Pierce.
And there you have it.
Buchanan and the court, Douglas and
the court, and Pierce and the court.
You can see why Lincoln might
have believed this conspiracy
actually happened.
Now, I don't want to give
you the wrong impression.
I'm not actually suggesting here
that these men really did
conspire to perpetuate slavery.
The evidence I sketched
here probably wouldn't hold
up in court today or
in the 19th century.
But I hope that I've
convinced you that even
if the Dred Scott conspiracy
may not have happened,
it was certainly possible
that it could have happened,
given the realities of
federal, and particularly,
judicial politics in the 1850s.
of course, there are a number
of important implications
for how the judicial system
operated in the Civil War era
that go beyond Lincoln and
this conspiracy theory.
And I'll just point out a few here.
First, we have to stop thinking
about the Supreme Court as separate
from the rest of the federal
government in the 19th century.
The judicial, executive and
legislative branches operated
in cooperative and overlapping ways.
Lincoln might have
been wrong that each
of these conspirators were
trying to nationalize slavery,
but he wasn't wrong that there was a
relatively free flowing conversation
happening among members of the
three branches about the future
of slavery in the nation.
Second, the federal judicial system
operated in fluid and informal ways.
Judges and the lawyers
who tried cases in front
of them often formed personal rather
than strictly business
relationships.
Moreover, there was
little consistency either
in how the federal courts operated,
or in the personnel present
for federal cases at
the circuit level.
In essence, the formality of
the legal system that we expect
in the 21st century
simply did not apply.
Judges shaped the federal court
system to suit their needs.
Finally, there is a
hint of elitism here.
Or perhaps more than a hint.
Members of the federal government
believed that they had answers
for what the United States
should look like going forward.
In Dred Scott alone, these answers
included the future of slavery,
citizenship, property rights and
congressional power, among others.
The people who were making these
decisions were at the highest levels
of government, making policy in
private conversations and deals.
This was not the popular democracy
we think of in the age of Jackson.
Public opinion simply
did not factor in.
And this is the last
piece of the puzzle
that we haven't really talked about.
How was Lincoln's conspiracy
charge actually received?
The evidence here is mixed.
While some partisans
encouraged Lincoln
to continue making his conspiracy
charge throughout his campaign
against Douglas in 1858, Lincoln
had largely dropped the matter
by the third joint debate.
Some scholars have taken this as
evidence that the voting public
in Illinois thought
Lincoln was delusional,
or at least unconvincing.
And perhaps he was.
Even if Lincoln had
intimate experience
with the Supreme Court's political
role his audience might not have.
The extent to which average
Americans understood the federal
court system and how it
operated is an open question.
One that I hope to explore
further in my research.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> ... a few questions,
so [inaudible].
>> Any questions?
>> First of all, thank
you very much.
>> Thank you.
>> [Inaudible] Propositions
you make about political nature
of the interactions between
branches, the suggestion is that,
that was then, and not now.
And I wondered if you would,
I mean, if, for example,
your model is that
that's how it was then...
>> Yeah.
>> And it is pristine
and pure now...
>> Oh, no.
I wouldn't say that...
>> But if it were, then I wonder
how the transition took place?
And if it's not, how far
along on the continuum is it?
>> That's a very good question.
I'm going to.
I'm going to be a little
bit hesitant to answer
because I'm a historian
of the 19th century,
and the 19th century is quite
different from the 21st century.
Certainly, a lot of this
stuff was happening well
into the 20th century.
You still had, for example,
Supreme Court Justices running
for president in the FDR era.
But, there clearly was
a change at some point.
One reason for this is probably the
actual implementation of law school
as the sort-of starting
ground for all lawyers.
Some of it has to do with
sort-of our growing concern
about the Supreme Court and whether
it should be making certain kinds
of decisions, activist
judging and that kind of stuff.
I think there's a lot more
political behavior that happens
on the Supreme Court
today, but that's more
as an observer than as a historian.
I think there's, there's
a problem with thinking
about the Supreme Court as
separate, in large part,
because it was not
separate from the beginning.
And so, if we have this originalist
interpretation of the court
as being this body that is
completely outside the bounds
of the rest of the
federal government,
we have a misunderstanding of the
way the court operated originally.
I'm not sure the justices
think of it that way today.
But certainly the public
does, as you suggested.
So, I'm sorry to not give you as
complete an answer as you'd like,
but as a 19th century historian,
I think I'd better stick
to my century [laughter].
>> It's not unusual to
the 19th century mind
to give out the slave power.
>> Um-hum.
>> If I knew that there was a
conspiracy implication involving
[inaudible] or slavery...
>> That's right.
>> But the problem
with any conspiracy is
that think about the execution.
And here you have volumes,
constantly bringing forth
the multi-member bodies.
So, assuming [inaudible] conspiracy,
was there any other [inaudible]
that Chief Justice Taney
and others were able to lean
on at last four other justices
to, in order to get a majority
in Dred Scott of 7 to 2,
McLean and Curtis dissenting.
>> That's correct.
>> Assuming evidence of Taney an
others leaning on other justices
to get them to go along
with this conspiracy.
>> Certainly that happened
in the case of Dred Scott.
There was a move to try to
get the other justices to get
on board with Taney's opinion.
And that's pretty common
throughout the 19th century,
that a Chief Justice, in
particular, is going to try
to get the other members
of the court to be in line
with the majority opinion.
He wasn't actually as successful
with it as he would have liked,
because there are also
quite a few concurrences
in the Dred Scott decision.
It's not a matter of just,
oh, there's a decision,
and there are a couple of dissents.
There is not a lot of
smoking gun evidence
about Taney getting
involved with congress
and putting pressure on congress.
But there were definitely
conversations happening.
So, it depends what you
think of as pressure.
There was at least an understanding
that this was something
that was open for discussion.
I actually think Taney
mistakenly believed
that this would actually quiet
all of the furor that was going
on in the rest of the country
about the slave power conspiracy.
He thought, oh, the court's
going to rule, and shut it down.
And they're not going to
talk about it anymore.
It did the exact opposite.
But, that doesn't mean
his intentions weren't
in this one particular place.
And I think that's just
a matter of him thinking
that the Supreme Court was as
important as he expected it to be
in making people listen
to what was going on.
>> You mentioned Supreme Court
Justices running for president?
>> Um hum.
>> In the FDR era, and
that was certainly true
of Charles Evans Hughes.
>> Um hum.
>> But he ran in 1916.
>> Yeah.
>> Has any justice run
subsequent to that?
>> Not actively.
This is not my specific area of
expertise but a lot of historians
of the Supreme Court and the 20th
century have said Hugo Black was
interested in running.
It's much more behind the
scenes than in the 19th century,
where it would have
been much more obvious
that someone like McLean
was running.
But, certainly, there were
justices who were interested
in running for president.
And working behind the scenes
to try to make it happen.
>> You mentioned that Lincoln
appointed one Supreme Court Justice
in 1862.
My question is, how
many did he appoint,
and can you talk a little bit about
what the confirmation process was
like in the 19th century?
>> Sure. Lincoln appointed
five, actually,
and was successful in all of these.
I bet you're surprised because
republicans controlled congress.
The process was actually very
partisan in the 19th century also.
Some of the best examples
of this are John Tyler,
who was president in
the early 1840s.
We think of him as a
man without a party.
He was vice president for
William Henry Harrison.
And he was supposedly a Whig
but the Whigs hated him.
And he tried to get nine
Supreme Court Justices.
He tried a couple of times
with two different guys.
And he only was successful with one.
It did not go well.
And one of the justices
positions was open
for two years while he was
waiting for a nomination.
And the very best example of
this is Roger Taney himself,
who was put up for
Supreme Court Justice
in an associate justice position
by Andrew Jackson in 1835,
was basically not confirmed
by the senate at this time.
It was a hostile senate.
Mostly people who were
opposed to Jackson.
The next year, there's turnover.
Get a new democratic senate.
And he puts Taney up for Chief
Justice, and it's confirmed.
So, that, the original
position that he was put up for,
associate justice, stayed open
for over a year while they
were waiting to fill that.
And so, it is a very
partisan process.
And was in the 19th century.
Other questions?
>> [inaudible]
>> Might not be true.
If Lincoln were correct
about the conspiracy, was it,
would it have been illegal?
Would laws have been broken?
Or just unethical?
Or amoral?
Or what?
>> That's a really good question.
And this is sort of at
the heart of my research.
Is to try to understand what was
considered ethically appropriate
in the 19th century.
And most of what happened
looks to be perfectly ethical
from the position of
most of the politicians
who were working in this period.
It's all legal, but they saw it
as perfectly within the bounds.
Whether this would
have been the reaction
of the public had they known really
what was going on, I'm not sure.
That's harder to figure out because
there aren't a lot of examples
of it becoming public knowledge.
So, we don't get a ton of outcry
about it, which means it's hard
to know what would happen
if it became more public.
But certainly Taney in
particular, saw himself as perfectly
within the law and behaving
in perfectly ethical ways.
>> We have time for one more.
>> [inaudible] ok.
>> Hello. In your talk, there
was one [inaudible] line,
about regardless of whether the
conspiracy actually existed, it's...
[inaudible].
Regardless of whether the conspiracy
actually existed, it seems,
the existence of conspiracy
seemed plausible
and therefore had political value
[inaudible] running for a position.
One reason, that to me is
the more interesting part
about the political value
of plausibility regardless
of the underlying facts.
Wonder if you can talk
a little bit more
about what the political
value was, and wasn't,
and how that played out...
[inaudible] connections to
seriously curious today.
>> [Laughter]
>> I also...
>> Well, so, this is part of.
This fellow right here.
I appreciate mentioning
the Slave Power Conspiracy.
It was part of a tradition
right around this time
since the early 1850s to say
that there was a conspiracy among
slaveholders to perpetuate slavery,
to do all they could to
spread slavery to the north.
And so, Lincoln is
participating in this tradition.
This Slave Power Conspiracy
suggestion.
And it was very effective
among republican voters.
They were very worried about
losing their own liberty.
They thought they were
going to lose their liberty
if slaveholders were able
to get control of the north.
Lincoln actually later made several
references to another court case
where he called the
second Dred Scott.
Which was going though the New
York court system at this time.
Lemons v. The People.
Which was another case
that involved New York,
whether slaveholders could
bring their slaves to New York.
And the New York legislature
had said no in 1841.
And this case was appealed
in the New York State Courts.
And the New York State Courts
had said no, it's totally fine
to ban slaveholders from bringing
their slaves into New York.
And Lincoln was afraid this was
going to get to the Supreme Court.
So there would actually be a
case where northern states had
to allow slavery in their states.
So, this is a situation where it
actually plays well to the fears
of northerners who think that our
state is free, our state allows me
to have the kind of
liberty that I want.
And now we're in a situation where
slaveholders might change that.
Because they're going to change
the circumstances on the ground.
It was a very powerful
argument at that time.
>> All right.
>> Thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.